foreign
[Music]
I'll be there on the 29th Sunday Seattle
I will be there get your tickets at
kristalia.com Portland and Seattle I'm
coming I'll also be in Daytona and
Lakeland Florida and Jacksonville get
your tickets at crystalia.com
and without further Ado welcome to
another episode of congratulations
congratulations
look at the end so yeah Seattle I'll be
there Sunday get your tickets at
chrysalia.com I'm excited I am excited
to do the road after two and a half
months I was in San Diego yes okay fine
I admitted I was in San Diego yes and I
did break California yes but I drove
there so I'm excited to take that flight
dude Cal uh Calvin and Kristen are
coming and I'm excited to take the blood
the flight and we're gonna kick up them
Vlogs the tour reports again so
subscribe to my channel uh the other
crystallia channel And subscribe to
super good we changed the uh name
because the word cult in it was Shadow
band and so now we just are gonna see
them subscribers
absolutely [ __ ]
um but yeah so uh no more Shadow ban
hopefully I mean I don't [ __ ] know
um but Shadow band Israel never thought
Shadow Banning was real but it is real
over a year without gaining any
subscribers yes and people told me hey I
was subscribe to your channel what
happened they got unsubscribed I don't
know hey yeah yes but anyway told him to
re-subscribe and these are friends
trusted people so
um yeah uh I am on tour go to
chrisley.com get the tour uh get the
tickets and then also there's that new
merch the life rips fall colorways with
the hoodie and then there's the new uh
uh welcome home join our cult shirts the
the flannels go on chrisley.com we got
the [ __ ] images right here they're
hot get them while they're hot fall is
nice am I a fan of fall you know what I
don't know if I'm a fan of fall what do
I like the most summer because it's most
comfortable I don't give a [ __ ] even if
it's 107 degrees I still love the heat I
do not like the cold the cold is
freezing and um I don't like the cold
also because
you know when you're wearing like
bundled up [ __ ] and then you go inside
and then the heat's on inside you got to
take off all your [ __ ] it's just really
really unbelievable and the storms have
been crazy here and everywhere in La
it's unbelievable uh uh and you know
what that means it brings out the
potholes babies it brings out the
potholes and me with the Low Pro Tires I
already [ __ ] fixed my tires about six
I've had six different tire new tires on
my [ __ ] Lowepro [ __ ] with the bloody
guts and it's just like yeah dude
but you know I guess that's the price to
pay for being practically Underground on
these you know I guess it's the price to
pay to be [ __ ] no higher than a
go-kart zipping around on the 101
freeway but you know
um
so it was in Brea California this past
weekend absolutely awesome so fun uh uh
you know I got the Reps in my voice is
going I think I'm screaming more in my
act now which I always get when I get a
little more confident with the material
so when you come when you see me
Portland and Seattle this weekend and
Florida next weekend when you see me
dude that's full confidence Dalia right
there dude but also
you know always fighting insecurity and
that's how it is dude
um always fighting insecurity always
fighting the fear of am I am I are
people accepting me so anyway but um I
always been that way since I was a kid
so it's all good but you know so
um we have a good time dude I was with
Denny love and Lulu Gonzalez do it [ __ ]
yeah man they kill it they're they're up
and coming Comedians and they are just
absolutely [ __ ] Killers the Brea uh
uh improv is absolutely it's so big it's
570 seats uh you know and it was all
full every show slight flex but man it
was just like crazy how like 200 2850
people uh came out to my Show's
lifelocks and it you know it's all good
but and also the weekend before that so
uh 3 600 tickets in San Diego which is
close to Brea's life Flex so and I still
sold out the [ __ ] improv 5 shows and
could have added another show but didn't
sci-fi so and anyway it's crazy dude
so is that like six thousand tickets
um
yeah dude we have a great time man God
damn I love doing stand up he's in love
with it again babies
oh he's in love with it again now for
[ __ ] sake God damn it oh he's in love
with it again uh when he came back a
year ago he wasn't [ __ ] in love with
it he fought to get on stage anyway
because he needed to show Calvin that
you can overcome demons and not be
scared of [ __ ] and oh for [ __ ] sake
dude it wasn't fun for a few months but
God damn it if he didn't fall in love
with it all over again oh [ __ ] dude you
fell in love with it all over again oh
for [ __ ] sake now what are we gonna do
and he's getting intimate on stage and
he's talking about Richard oh he's
[ __ ] God damn it you know what I mean
he knows how to crush but now he takes
his time out for [ __ ] sake
[Laughter]
crushed them [ __ ] minutes per lap for
[ __ ] crazy but now he's [ __ ]
taking his time with him my baby's oh
[ __ ] dude I got everything he's taking
his time with it
in the middle he [ __ ] takes his time
up for [ __ ] sake and people get quiet
and then listen after [ __ ] sake dude
you can hear a pin drop for [ __ ] sake
but that's all by Design app for [ __ ]
sake God damn it dude
um
yeah dude so uh I have a good time on
stage fall in love with Comedy All Over
Again on crystallias Don't Push Me Tour
this summer fall in love with Comedy All
Over Again
um don't push me
starring crystalia only
uh yeah I saw two movies
I saw three movies
but one of them I saw for the fourth
time dude now
what do we know about crystallia if
you've been [ __ ] listening to the
congratulations podcast and you're a
part of this called what have we been
what have we learned now Chris what do
you not do you don't watch movies twice
yes that's correct okay hi Chris I'm
here to ask the hard-hitting questions
do you watch movies twice I don't and if
you listen to my podcast you know that
oh interesting so you only watch them
once yes what if you really like them I
only watch them once because I don't
want to ruin the experience I had
originally oh isn't that nice and you
already know what's happening yeah it is
a little of that but I'll tell you man I
really only watch videos movies once
are there select movies that you watch
more than once yes there are what are
they they're either my my very favorite
movies which about five of them oh okay
so is that what you saw this this uh
this past week no it's not well what
well I thought you said you only watched
your absolute favorite movies more than
once yeah there's like five of them well
but you saw this movie more than once
yeah but it's not one of your favorite
ones no well why did you watch it well
because it's utterly [ __ ] atrocious
well what is it gods of Egypt that's
what it is
oh with Gerard Butler and the guy from
Game of Thrones uh-huh
is it really that bad yes how bad is it
it's the worst Hollywood film I've ever
seen in my life oh very interesting
what's it about well it's about a bunch
of Persians and they're played by a
bunch of white guys and they turn into
[ __ ] things like wolves and Eagles
and they fly around and one guy turns
into a troll and blood comes out of them
when they get stabbed oh okay well I can
certainly understand that
it makes no sense
the movie makes zero sense you watch it
and then I found out that somebody got
hired to rewrite it because it made no
sense and this is the version that they
came out with Gerard Butler's in a dude
how much is Gerard Butler only make
movies depending on two things never
number number one how much money he's
getting and number two how hot the
chicks are in the country that they're
shooting it yes dude
no doubt he goes like this well how much
are they paying me 10 million that's a
lot where is it it's in the [ __ ]
Greek Islands
[Music]
get my dick out
isn't a movie called plane
the movie coming out is called plane
it's not even the plain movie it's just
plain
it's with him and the guy in that show
evil that's been on for five years for
some reason
there's a show called evil that's been
on for like six years how
is there a show that's been on for six
years that your boy Johnny Hollywood has
no idea about
Hollywood's not even trying anymore dude
I love it that's what I love that's by
the way what I love like when they say
oh when we made Snakes on a Plane I go
hey Hollywood's back and then of course
they went along with their on the walk
[ __ ] no no they're not gonna get
back anymore
um yeah dude so so yes I watch gods of
Egypt yes I watch gods of Egypt yes okay
yes [ __ ] I did I watched it and I
watched it I've seen it four times and
I've seen it twice in the past two weeks
why because it's [ __ ] atrocious and I
love it dude
okay
and I always tell my brother when I'm
watching it and he always says again and
I said you have to dude and then I
stopped watching it and then I came
across this no I finished watching it
and then I came across this movie called
soft and quiet and wow did that [ __ ]
send me
into
a holy [ __ ] moment it's a great movie
it's all in one shot which I hate it's
gimmicky but it works for this movie
um and it's about a bunch of like-minded
moms that come together uh because they
want to uh
promote their Aryan race
you know they're white moms and one
thing leads to another and it just goes
out of control and it's absolutely
[ __ ] insane and you got to see that
movie dude and the music in that movie
is [ __ ] killer and it's all made for
the movie and I don't even know how they
did it they shot the movie four days in
a row
from at 6 34 PM they started and they
just went and they shot it like a play
dude you know how [ __ ] hard that is
now granted it's a little bit easier
because you get done with the movie in
four days because I'll tell you I'll
tell you this much gods of Egypt was
definitely shot in three months
um
yeah but it was phenomenal that movie
was great I don't know why no not more
people are talking about it so I am but
it's great
um
yeah you got to see that movie
I've been watching movies and then I
also watched another movie I can't
remember what the [ __ ] it was smile dude
is great I don't want to talk about only
movies but smile is great it's about
trauma once I realize that I [ __ ] go
like this oh like the weeabe meme
um
yeah
so
talking about movies too much for sure I
saved the [ __ ] dog on the freeway so
congratulations dude to me I saved a dog
on the freeway
and man I put it on Instagram I didn't
even like think about how like people
would react I was just like oh this is
cool I should you know it's kind of cute
I put it on and do it you know it's just
like
I'm back
dude it's like
I ended the war in the Ukraine
when you save a dog dude
you're Black Adam
when you save a dog
you Black Adam
and uh I did do it I did this dog was
weaving in and out of traffic like
looked like a [ __ ] dingo looked like
a coyote the way it was walking kind of
thinner but also had a collar on so I
was like okay I'm just gonna go look at
the [ __ ] thing
and I was like what do I do like these
cars were swerving out of the way and
everything was slowing down he was just
in the [ __ ] middle of the freeway
like I know dogs aren't as smart as
humans but ah get out of the way you
know you're in the [ __ ] these big ass
these vehicles they're gonna hit you you
know that right
your owner's throwing a ball before you
know that the ball has velocity and you
got to go after it and you know that it
could hit you right uh a car's way
bigger move
so I um
I was like driving slowly and then
finally he kind of like trotted over to
the side of the freeway and I was like
all right everyone's just driving by I
guess I gotta pull over and try to save
this [ __ ] help this guy he's gonna
get creamed by a [ __ ] Hyundai right
and we're gonna have to give him to a
[ __ ] Asian restaurant so I [ __ ] uh
so I pull over and the dog is is uh kind
of there and I get off I get out of the
car car's whizzing by me and people are
like [ __ ] honking like ribs I'm like
can't do it another day dude I'm trying
to I mean
honking is that the guy from yeah okay I
get it but please dude I'm just trying
to help
and uh doesn't make a dent no I know but
dude please I just
so I I get the uh I I look at the dog
and I say hey but I do this thing look
I don't put on a show for a dog just
because it's a dog especially if it's in
trouble I noticed that the the the the
the tail is UN is under you know it's
it's I've never seen a dog so scared the
tail was under so much it was tickling
the tip of his dick right like it was
just scooping under just touching just
touching this [ __ ] friendly gland you
know what I'm talking about just
scooping under
the dog just did the dog's tail was just
scooping under just lightly grazing that
frenulum gland you know what I mean
just absolutely if it happened too long
if the dog I left early but it you know
I don't know the dog could have squirted
you know I don't know his his tail was
just edging the [ __ ] out of his frenulum
gland and uh
that's how scary he was
the dog's like I'm so scared I need to
feel some pleasure that's why that's why
dogs tails go in between their legs when
they're scared because they're scared
they don't want to feel that they can
cope with it so they need to you know
[ __ ] with the frenulum gland so they
feel some sort of you know dopamine hit
which is basically what I've been doing
my whole life so um
so the dog you know it's rubbing his
friends gland with the tip of his
and uh and it's scared so I don't put on
a show for a dog just because this is a
dog now look I do this with my son I'd
be like hey buddy like I don't normally
walk up to people that are regular and
just I'm like hey buddy what's going on
oh nice jacket you gotta see on it
what's that stand for like I don't do
that
and I don't but I I I I do it with with
my son because I love him so much and
it's so cute but with a dog I realize
the cuteness and let me tell you
something about this dog this dog was
fantastically handsome okay and
but I know what's up dude I'm gonna
treat the dog like a regular person
because I don't want this dog to think
I'm putting on a show because I don't
want him to think oh wait what is this
guy acting like this way I don't want I
don't why is this guy acting so nice to
me he must want something he must want
to [ __ ] eat Meers right like this is
like it's very dogs are very Russian
you know like you can't walk up this is
why Russians are just like Hello nice to
meet you thank you for a bouquet of
flowers like they don't smile if for any
reason then if it feels like like
they're only Russians only smile after
they realize they're smiling
they're never like hi hello nice to meet
you yes because that in their culture
means you want something from me right
you you're trying to trick me
I am no dog
as he walks away touching his frenulum
tip
um so dogs are very Russian
you know you can be like hey buddy right
but if a dog's
scooped up with his tail tickling his
frenulum he's scared as [ __ ] and he
knows something's up he's on high alert
already and I'm not getting this I'm not
getting my jugular bit
right
so I'm far away from the dog I'm talking
30 40 feet
but I say hey buddy and he she's
trotting away turns back around looks at
me and I say hey uh hey come here man
come here buddy let me talk to you like
I'm just treating him like a [ __ ]
homie hey come here man
and he just kind of looks at me for a
little bit trots a little bit over and I
say what you doing can I pet you or what
any any he comes a little closer I kneel
down and he walks away right so I'm like
okay
number one think number one it's too bad
because now I don't know what to do and
I can't really help him he's not gonna
let me touch him but number two secretly
happy because he's part pit now I know
you're not supposed to say pit bulls
[ __ ] eat people but you know
foreign
people's faces off I know but then I'm
like okay well but you know who
definitely does in his Yorkies
that's all I'm saying you ever seen a
Havanese you know what I mean stuck on
somebody's jugular no okay
that's all I'm saying and look
I know maybe
there's Pitbull activists out there
they're great dogs and you you know you
raise them I think they'd have the
problems to do with the humans okay you
want to be like yo it's a human problem
they're raising them to be this way fine
I don't know what human owned this pit
bull earlier
so the last thing I want is his jaw
locked around my jugular
especially when he's scared tickling the
[ __ ] out of his gland you know what's up
right so
so I say hey uh
you know another guy pulls over you know
he's like the Robin I'm Batman and uh
and and uh he's getting nowhere with the
dog because he it was my [ __ ] from jump
I know I'm like buddy thank you
I got this it's like you know it's like
the FBI when the cops when the when the
when the FBI shows up at the cops and
they're like we got it from here that
was me right the guy was just some
[ __ ] like some fat Sergeant that's
just like we don't like you we don't
need you here and I'm just like buddy
this is my jurisdiction okay he's in my
area
this has this is a federal [ __ ] thing
I need to get this dog to stop [ __ ]
with his frenulum now let's go or he's
gonna get hit by a car
[Music]
hey guys I want to take a little bit of
a break and talk to you about something
called ship station if you don't live
under a rock you already know what it is
but let me educate you all right
um a new year is full of possibilities
but when your e-commerce business is
dealing with gift returns late
deliveries and a mountain of customer
emails you can feel stuck okay I use
shipstation I love my merch team we have
a lot of big goals for 2023 and we are
super pumped to have ship station in our
corner like always
um they're just great they really help
no matter what kind of e-commerce
business you have it's amazing ship
station makes it easy to grow your
business by handling your orders from
every platform in one place ship station
effortlessly integrates everywhere you
sell online including Amazon Etsy eBay
Shopify and obviously more plenty more
manage every order from one simple
dashboard automate routine shipping
tasks print shipping labels you can do
it all you can easily compare rates uh
and with the best discounts in the
industry you'll never wonder if you're
getting the best rates trust me on that
get up to 86 off USPS and UPS rates what
that's no small fries if that's not
enough check this out use my promo code
for you listeners here of
congratulations use my promo code to try
shipstation free for two months over 130
companies have grown their e-commerce
business with shipstation they can't be
wrong
make the New Year your best year and
grow your business with ship station use
promo code congrats today at
shipstation.com to sign up for your free
60-day trial that's two months at
shipstation.com promo code congrats
[Music]
so uh I I finally uh get him a little
bit closer to my car and then he walked
around my car and tries to walk into the
[ __ ] traffic again and I say hey
buddy come here I put this on my
Instagram you can see
and I open up my car door so I'm like oh
maybe he'll just hop in the car and I'm
like I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
gonna do because I have a show in Brea
I'm driving to Brea but I'm like I guess
I'm gonna bring this dog to my show
because
I can't bring them anywhere else I
already tried to call animal control or
animal pickup or whatever the [ __ ] you
call them you know dog catchers
um and nobody's picking up so it's up to
me dude I'm like [ __ ] okay you know I
work alone
I don't want a [ __ ] partner
I only work alone
and so
I opened up my car door the dog looks at
me like bro what and I say not just you
know just get in we'll go to a comedy
show it's fine still in between his legs
and then people are driving by and I'm
like dude they're gonna see Crystal
you're trying to get a dog in the back
somebody's gonna take a video and the
[ __ ] TMZ is gonna be like ah Crystal
here tries to [ __ ] a dog in the back
seat of his car I'm like all right you
know
so I'm like all right I closed the door
and then I I'm like I gotta get this
[ __ ] dog out of the freeway he's on
the freeway so there's like a
uh um um
uh a hill that's very Steep and I got
new shoes on
shout out to divick he makes awesome
[ __ ] shoes I got on the [ __ ] cool
they're the you know you don't I don't
know if you give a [ __ ] about shoes but
I do and they're camouflaged and they
got that D on it and they're real nice
divk
and um shout out to divik
uh and so I I'm climbing up the um
I'm like all right well let's I look and
there's a gate all the way above the the
hill
and I'm like all right I'm gonna get him
over there over to that gate I hope
there's an opening I'm gonna get him
over there so they won't be in the
freeway at least maybe there's like
somebody out there that can help or
maybe the place looks not you know it
looks kind of safe so I said come here
buddy and he [ __ ] starts running up
the hill with me and I'm like [ __ ] yeah
dude now it's me and him it's like
Turner and Hooch we're just running up
the hill dude
and uh and I see there's an opening and
there's a [ __ ] latch like it's just
so perfect there's a latch where I could
open the gate and like and I said come
out here and I lead him out to the gate
and he walks out of the gate and I say
okay buddy can I pet you and he just
kind of walks away still and I'm like
okay and I closed the gate behind him
and dude
I saved the [ __ ] dog's life
because he didn't get hit with a [ __ ]
thing and I'm like bye buddy and I got
like not very emotional but I was like
wow this is I hope he's okay and he was
in a very safer way safer area you know
I'm sure somebody called he didn't have
tags on so I couldn't call anybody
and the dog catches don't work on
[ __ ] Friday or whatever but anyway I
saved the dog I felt good I went back
and I went to my shows and I did two
shows sold out whatever slide flex but
it's all good dude
save the dog and slept and sold out the
shows but it's all good
media report that I saved the [ __ ]
dog huh nah they won't do that
it's not salacious so um
yeah so I you know I felt good I hope
that dog was good and then and then
Kristen saw I sent the videos to her and
she's like get him bring him in and I
was like we're not dude
she was like bring him home please and
we got four
I didn't want Chen's though we got a
[ __ ] dog that literally is a trash
dog
and yeah I understand he's your
emotional support animal now and like he
caught us a [ __ ] at you but dude I'm not
we're not bringing a [ __ ] pit bull
back
with four now we got five dollars why
are we gonna just open up a shelter
so babe are you out there
are you listening
is that her I don't know she's not I
thought she was breathing through the
door maybe it was maybe it was honestly
Chen's are laughing
um but yeah so I saved the dog
and uh
and it feels good you know
I can't believe how many people were not
and then people were like online
somebody was saying something like oh
dude why'd you post about it if you were
Christian you wouldn't and I was like
guess what not Christian
[Music]
but it kind of am you know I've been
praying a little bit been trying feel
phony when I do it but I still try to do
it I pray for my enemies did you know
that I pray for my enemies I do I pray
for my enemies and I pray for my haters
and I gotta be honest it's a little bit
because I heard you know I know I've
heard Tupac did that
uh and you know a lot of good hit they
did him he wound up dead but I'm saying
but you know honestly did he live the
life he was supposed to because he's
influenced many people and if he didn't
die would he have influenced that many
people I don't know but all I'm saying
is I pray for my enemies
and so that's what I do now and I do
that and I do it honestly through
gritted teeth but I feel like the more I
do it the better I'll get at it and I
don't think I'm I think I'm missing the
point honestly because I do it like and
[ __ ] you know what I'm gonna pray for
this [ __ ] but I'm getting better
at it because I want to be open and I
want to have love for all and that's the
oh that is the goddamn truth dude that's
the goddamn truth I prefer my enemies
dude
that's why I [ __ ] your [ __ ] you fat
[ __ ] sorry
um
um
yeah
[Music]
and uh we love it
so yeah so you know we're firing in all
syllables we're having a good time we're
doing the podcast and uh we're on the
road we love it
um I was at coffee today and uh I
brought my Kristen was getting her hair
done I had to drop dry bar blow dry dry
blow blow bar blow dry bar right the
yellow and white place and uh and she
was getting her hair blowed and uh I was
like okay I mean I wasn't like okay I
don't know why I said that part's just
filling in silence but uh she said why
don't you come to Mel's Diner and bring
Calvin it'll be fun and I I say is that
your dry bar place and she said yeah and
I said most Dunner is a [ __ ] travesty
sucks you know it's terrible it's on
Sunset and only tourists go there and I
have no beef against tourists but like
it's not good food it doesn't have to be
good food because it's on Sunset
Boulevard and tourist go there do you
understand what I'm saying do you get
what I'm saying now so she was like yeah
but it'll be fun it's like a 1950s Diner
so now I'm like okay Kristen's a Cuda
but it's all good but we're all cudas
right we're all kind of get suckered
into that [ __ ] every now and then and
I'm gonna sucker for a good atmosphere
too I really am dude I used to love this
strip club
so um
so so Kristen's like meet me at the uh
at the at the and I'm like okay well we
could you know I was like when are you
done she said 2 30 I said okay that's
fine uh I'm gonna probably be uh ready
sooner than that I'll bring Calvin I'm
gonna go sit near the Coffee Bean until
if you know how I do it and I want to
get Cal Calvin kind of indoctrinated in
the whole system here
um
so she says cool go to the Coffee Bean
and Tea Leaf and then I'll hit you up
when I'm done so I'm at the Coffee Bean
to leave I'm having a really great time
with Calvin he's got his life riff
jacket on his denim jacket which uh it
was made by on Instagram his name is
seamstress he's [ __ ] great and uh he
made me and Calvin some matching life
reps jackets and uh Calvin was kind of
you know we were hanging having a good
time he had his little centipede toy and
uh I was born bubbles with the coffee it
was really cute and uh so then Kristen
is like hey I'm done where do you want
to meet and I said well you know we're
really close to this Cafe that I like
called dialogue which is great they got
a great brisket burrito and I wanted it
but then she said oh okay I said or we
can go to Mel's you know but it's a
little further for us and she says let's
go to Mel's so I go like this
okay because I'm a good person oh I want
to go to dialogue Cafe but I swallowed
that so we go to Mel's because I do
think actually males will probably be
more fun for Calvin and also that's
where Krista wants to go and honestly I
live life outside myself now okay used
to be a selfish guy dealing with it
battling demons but also my heart's on
the outside above my body at this point
like I said I pray for my enemies
so
so we go to Mel's and we have Mel's and
why did I start talking about this oh no
so I was at the coffee and I'm at the
coffee and I go to leave the Coffee Bean
I get in the car I put Calvin in the car
seat I know there's always like I said
if you know something about this podcast
I talk about coffee shops all the time
because I go I'm a regular baby I love
it and
um when I go there
uh there's always what one crazy person
at a coffee shop is never more than one
it's always like one guy I have a
feeling it's a conspiracy and there's
always need to be like one crazy dude
and I think it's so people won't sit
there and post up and stay on the Wi-Fi
with just a 450 dollar a 400 of a 4.50
[ __ ] macchiato for like seven hours
at a time so the crate I can't be around
this crazy guy anymore right I think
that that it's a good thing that coffee
shops do so this guy's a crazy guy he's
one of those guys that [ __ ] decals
his car all up he's like a holly Dennis
Woodruff is his name go to
denniswood.com he's a [ __ ] guy
someday he'll walk up and he'll be like
hey man I really like your comedy and
sometimes I see him and he walks up and
he says I watch your special man you're
not [ __ ] funny so I'm like all right
dude look just pick one or don't pick
and don't talk to me
so I never know what honestly I know
honestly I don't know what Dennis I'm
gonna get but that I don't want even one
Dennis Woodruff so the guy [ __ ] uh
knocks I get a knock on my uh
bloody guts Calvin's in the back seat
and I I look I see a bomber Jack I don't
see the face I open up the door like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] by the way
I don't even see who it is I just see a
bomber jacket and I open up the door God
could have [ __ ] shanked me
the [ __ ] could have like dragged
me out and beat the [ __ ] out of me I
don't know who the [ __ ] it is I just huh
I see I opened a door and it's this
[ __ ] guy Dennis Woodruff one time
he's at the Coffee Bean and he just had
an astronaut helmet on like this is the
kind of guy I'm dealing with and he's
got his dog near my car and I don't want
his dog to jump up and scrape that
[ __ ] Pearl mat what you know that
white the pearl white mat you know what
I'm saying it's hard to match the paint
with a [ __ ]
she's got a big dog in his I don't want
him to I don't want him to scratch up my
car so I go oh hey and he says is that a
sunroof on your car and I said yeah man
he said oh that's bitching I said oh
thanks man and I closed the door and I'm
just like I try to eat out of the um
driveway and from the back I hear Calvin
say it was really nice to see him
[Laughter]
and I was like oh yeah
yeah and it's like dude
no it's not but also A Life Lesson right
A Life Lesson an acceptance A Life
Lesson in do I really pray for my
enemies because if I did I could sit
here and just breathe through this and
understand that this is a person with a
mental condition and that's okay yeah
he's monopolizing some some of my time
and yeah it makes my heart hot and yeah
it makes my [ __ ] Palm sweaty but you
know what dude life is good and my son
he's not jaded I am
so maybe it was nice to see him I tell
you man as a dad your son or your
children they teach you some [ __ ]
you just got to be open to understanding
it so now next time I see Dennis
Woodruff
depending on what you know I'm gonna try
and be in a good if I'm in a good mood
I'm not going to let it get in this is
the stuff I'm gonna take if I'm in a bad
mood and he says something to me I'm
going to be like okay you know great but
if I'm in a good mood I'm not gonna let
him move me over push me over to a
[ __ ] bad mood I'm gonna stay in that
good mood and be like you know what
Dennis Rodrick in my head I'm gonna be
like yeah I'm at the problems and that's
fine but I accept you and you know what
it really was nice to see you
and then I'm going to [ __ ] go on my
way
it was really nice to see him
my legs caught my legs caught
um
anyway
you know of course uh and then we went
to Mel's Diner and we okay so I was
talking [ __ ] about my most Diner in the
beginning so I we went there and look I
like to say I'm not a Cuda to [ __ ]
just grab it you know if you don't
because I don't know what a coda is it's
a [ __ ] barracuda and they just go to
Chinese objects because they're shiny
they don't really have much thought into
them and so that's what I say when
somebody's accuda they just are tricked
into going into a place because of
another reason than they actually want
it so
um it's just programmed in their head
because we know we all got a little bit
of Kuda in us but
like the guy who just gets [ __ ] hot
sauce chocolate hot hot chocolate sauce
on his [ __ ] ice cream and doesn't
even think about if he wants it or not
just because like oh that sounds nice
but it's like wait a minute I'm actually
an ice cream purist and I don't want to
have like [ __ ] like dude how about
this actually and I I digress but ice
cream is good enough all the places
where it's like come on in and see
whatever toppings you want go [ __ ]
yourself dude Eminems no thanks gummy
bears are you out of your mind one time
I was at a place and they had [ __ ]
pepperonis
and so I'm just like no that's
disgusting but ice cream's fine but
anyway I digress so
we go to Mel's and I see on the thing
I'm like I've been eating like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] lately you know I had a burger
the night before and a burger the night
before that and they were both a mess
they weren't like you know what I mean
good burgers they were great the way
they but they were [ __ ] you know what
I mean
and uh like chef's kiss of course but
also you know doctor's kiss too because
they're gonna see me sooner now that I
ate them and uh
uh
so I I I've been eating like an [ __ ]
I'm gonna get something light like a
salad but then I'm looking at the menu
and I'm like I'm not gonna get a salad
at a diner if you get a salad at a diner
honestly I can't even think of a bigger
piece of [ __ ] person than does that and
then unless you're a woman I get it but
like a guy who gets a salad at a 1950s
Diner like
a piece of [ __ ] right
um
and then also like so anyway so anyway
right
um so anyway I I look and I'm looking
and I see this section that's called
Arnold Schwarzenegger's protein
section
or something and I'm like what the [ __ ]
did Arnold Schwarzenegger agree to this
[ __ ] on the menu
you know 100 just agrees to everything
they're just like we want to put three
items on a [ __ ] 1950s Diner on Sunset
Boulevard and name it after you is that
okay and he's just like oh yeah
what's on it it doesn't that actually
doesn't matter just put it on there
so
um I look at the thing and it's got a uh
eggs
uh uh chicken
slices of tomato which is [ __ ]
honestly eating tomatoes is like eating
nothing
and then and then you also get
um what else tomatoes chicken oh yeah
asparagus which is cool you know I like
my pee stinky so
and I see it's called protein the
protein plate I hate when people talk
about protein because usually it's like
people who are just like
they look like [ __ ] sausages and
they're just like big but they're like
not cut and they're like You Gotta Eat
protein and you're like bro talk to me
when you can do laundry on your abs
um and uh
so but I gotta I'm like this is kind of
what I want it's kind of light it's kind
of nice so I'm like I'll just get the
protein plate she says oh okay great
protein plate comes dude and it was
great so I didn't want to talk [ __ ]
about
Mel's Diner I I haven't been there in 20
years I got the same waitresses by the
way I've been there in 20 years I used
to go when I was coming up in Hollywood
and um last time I went was with Eric
Youngman and Denis Testa two friends of
mine so I haven't seen them in a bit but
you know uh went to went to the 1950
Diner and ate that [ __ ] and it was
really good and then I wasn't done dude
you know I wasn't done because there
were no carbs in the goddamn plate
if you don't eat carbs it's not really a
meal is it
didn't eat any breads uh my son got
chicken fingers ate none of them I
didn't even need any of those
so I'm still hungry so I look under the
[ __ ]
thing
at the menu and there's a protein shake
now I gotta say protein again but I
don't it's not called a protein shake
what it's called is the protonator
and I'm like well I'm not saying this
do you know what I'm saying I want all
of the ingredients but I don't want the
umbrella it's under so I say to her can
I get the protein shake that's also on
that section and she says the protonator
and I said you said it she brought it
back and it was okay it was pretty good
so anyway I'm full of protein
um and I don't like when people say that
but I am
so uh that's what's up Diana schwarzick
has his own [ __ ] I want a guy like
the Arnold Schwarzenegger is too that's
the thing he's too famous for me to have
somebody like if they honestly talk to
me I'll go to the restaurant that gives
Greg Kinnear a [ __ ] section
um
but yeah
I saw in this article here this is on
BuzzFeed which so you know it's
hard-hitting facts
BuzzFeed news right there's Bud BuzzFeed
and then BuzzFeed news I guess which is
hilarious like that's they're trying to
be like the
and there's an article I saw Timothy
chalamet's agent revealed that he hadn't
hasn't auditioned for anything in over
seven years and it sparked a
conversation about nepotism privilege
and Industry connections
okay
this article dude
so look apparently they were trying to
have Timothy chalamet
do Gladiator too which is sounds like
literally a fake movie they would make a
a whole arc on in the show Entourage
Like Gladiator two
like does it another Gladiator or what
the guy's dead so
I would go see it I will go see if it
was Gladiator t-o-o and it was like oh
this guy's Gladiator too this guy's a
gladiator too
um but like
not even a prequel
so then and also and also you want
Timothy Sheldon he better be the bad guy
the guy wears more [ __ ] Sparkles than
any Chick I've ever met
he's not going to be the Russell Crowe
part right Gladiator could only be
played by a guy who you know is going to
be fat when he's 60. you know what I'm
talking about
uh what's his name's Gonna Get Timothy
chalamet is going to get thinner
he's going to be willing to Foe and [ __ ]
when he gets older only way more
handsome now I get William to vote sexy
he's got his own [ __ ] going on but
you know he wears Sparkles and [ __ ] so
uh uh anyway this guy is going to play
Gladiator in Glad here too really
Scott's going to do it so
that'd be good look at these [ __ ]
guys dress
um
so apparently Timothy chalamet's agent
Brian swordstrom which is a [ __ ] name
that would be in a movie and Tom Cruise
would play the LA the the [ __ ]
Anthony swordstrom would be the [ __ ]
Tom Cruise Guy and um
quick he quickly entered the
conversation to refute the viral rumors
now first of all
this is what the agent
wrote I know one of these actors was
shooting a film because they were saying
who's going to play the role in and
there was like is it Tiffany is it this
guy and this guy his agent to the
shopping said I know one of these actors
was shooting a film in the Middle East
for the past several months and he
hasn't auditioned for anything in more
than seven years he tweeted now the fact
that your agent tweets anything
is terrible
and about you
starable that was that is a fireable
offense
if I was Timothy chalamet I'd put on my
sparkly [ __ ] Blazer and Tweet back
you're fired okay
and with a little [ __ ] tie that like
you know the little tie not even the bow
tie the one with the two things that
come down like a [ __ ]
so because Brian's Tweet now hello
an agent has entered the chat now what
do we all know about agents
everyone hates them no matter what so
hey agent don't tweet about me I'm all
good
so his tweet sparked a mixed reaction
from fans many of whom thought Timothy's
industry connections into uh who brought
Timothy's industry connections into
question the 27 year old uncle is
director Rodman flender
remember him
remember Rodman flender
huh
no ah
then why is this an article
while his maternal grandfather was
writer and screenwriter Harold flinder
oh that's why it sounded familiar it
wasn't Rodman flender it was Harold
flender right
no you still don't know
oh right then why is this article
written
dude and Timothy's mom Nicole flender is
also an actor known for her roles in
movies
the bird watcher and the heat of passion
how many times you see in those movies
zero oh okay then why is this an article
dude
it says given that Timothy by the way
e e you know
with an accent over the first e
who shot to Fame after starring in the
first film yet come by your name
question whether it's a success in the
industry is supposed to do their
familiar connections I got your answer
right here no
okay
I mean no dude
and for this reason several fans argued
that Timothy not partaking in any
auditions in several years was proof of
his privilege in the Hollywood industry
he's got privilege in the Hollywood
industry because he's slaying these
parts
he's got clout in the industry because
he's absolutely obliterating his choices
and Scripts
he's out there picking up
I mean it's so
look somebody some Asian chick wrote
this is not the flex you think it is
look at this Hollywood is giving him
special treatment chalamet is a nepo
baby but a lot of people don't know that
because but he has an uncle in the
industry that opened a lot of doors for
him dude how about like everybody
dude how about how
their how about how every industry you J
look my dad is a producer okay people
think that literally people like my
comedy because my dad worked on Ally
McBeal
do you know what I'm saying people think
that literally
fans buy tickets to my shows
because my dad directed a few episodes
of Lois and Clark
like they think that
you know how hard it is dude this is the
industry that we grew up in and I say we
me and Timothy telling me because we're
both [ __ ] complete we have star power
you know the same and you know it's like
yeah he was in Dune but did he [ __ ]
does he have a sold out Show in Seattle
I mean he doesn't you know what I mean
I'd like to see him try to stand up is
all I'm saying like yeah I get it he was
in [ __ ] whatever that movie was uh uh
call me by your name and you know that
was great but I'd like to see him go try
to do two shows at the beacon on
February 15th chrisley.com um
so I don't think you would do very and
obviously honestly even if you could
sell tickets I don't think he would do
very well so and that's fine but I'm
saying put me in his roles
I'll clean up
I'll clean up and it's not I'm not
saying
you know
I I I get it but you put
I'm not trying to say one's better than
the other but you put me in Dune and
it's a different story I mean I know a
lot of people liked it but you put me in
doing it's a different story dude and I
mean people go like this
okay wow all right well yeah he's a
force to be reckoned with I know I'm not
going to say it's a [ __ ] what do they
call it tour de force
but
so all I honestly it's my gold address
like Timothy chalamet though 100 when
I'm 60 though when I'm 60.
um
so anyway you know it's like look at
this person tweets they're a real
conversations to be had about white
privilege but Timothy Shadow may not
audition for roles right now isn't this
is where this is where he is in his
career he's not the First Act to be in
the position I won't be the last yeah
for sure 100 who said that
um
I kind of if I was Timothy shall I might
do I would be so angry at my age and her
age and shut up you know
uh so anyway uh that's there you have it
dude it's not because of nepotism dude
the guy's a good actor I guess right he
massages the lens I'll give them that
much is he good I don't know or is he
massaging the lens you know I've seen a
few movies with Timothy chalamet maybe
only one and he massages the lens I'll
give him that much
um but yeah I mean it's just insane
these people don't get mad at [ __ ]
anything
how about this get mad at Frankie Muniz
for being a NASCAR driver
that shouldn't have happened in this
world right
now I've met Frankie Muniz the nicest
guy in the [ __ ] world want the best
for him but dude
I want you to be Agent Cody Banks I want
you to do 11 of those movies
I want you to do more Malcolm in the
Middle I want Malcolm to not only be in
the middle I want him to be on the left
and the right
like dude I want honestly
what's his name Frankie Muniz to be I
mean the guy's four six and I think that
that's [ __ ] fantastic man I want you
to play
always in movies I want you to be bad
guys I want you to be the illest James
Bond villain how about that oh my God
I'll tell you right now Frankie Muniz if
he was a James Bond villain game over
so he does NASCAR he didn't want to do
acting and uh
Frank commune is known as Malcolm
Stars starts NASCAR career
look at this there might be a reboot on
the horizon for actor Frankie Muniz one
aptly titled Malcolm in the Middle of a
pile up sabad not funny I'm Munich has
started Malcolm in the Middle and Agent
Cody Banks announced that he was that
this week he's competing in a full-time
race car and driver in the he's going to
die you know like and here's the deal
that because that makes so much sense
that headline Frankie Muniz dies first
car Nascar race like you know it just
makes too much sense
I think he misses calling he should have
been a jockey dude that would have been
amazing but it's probably good for
lighter guys to do NASCAR [ __ ] because
they don't have although maybe it's good
to have the weight you know because once
you get the velocity going I'm really
[ __ ] I know a lot about science and
[ __ ] and math
uh and it all comes down to Velocity
um anyway congratulations to Frankie
Munoz to do his first race We Love
Frankie Muniz here at the
congratulations podcast I Love Frankie
Munoz I like him more than Timothy
Channel I mean honestly I wish Frank
Munoz was in doing
um
how confusing is that title call me by
your name call me by your name call me
by your name is that what the movie is
call me by your name
yeah
also oh wait hold on Timothy chalamet
his sister is also in the business Dude
any business
any business
you do
is mostly a [ __ ] because you're like
oh I know that guy well why don't you
hire this guy so and then when it comes
to Hollywood everyone gets all pissed
off because everyone wants to be in
Hollywood and people think it's because
they're brown or something or a lesbian
that they didn't get the part we're
gonna realize you just don't know
anybody and I don't you know what I mean
like if that's not that doesn't come
from my place I hate I'm just saying I
might have to cut that part out we're
not we're not cutting that part out so
um because I'm real
um
I'm just honestly happy at hey we talked
about a lot about movies we're going to
talk more about movies
I got a question for Hollywood
hey Hollywood what you doing
hey Hollywood
let's talk about this 80 for Brady
hey Hollywood
what you doing
I want to know
80 for Brady it's a movie about four
women that are a hundred and eleven
that are Tom Brady fans and want to go
watch football games okay is basically
what it is that's the law that's the
line that they pitched
um for sure
so here it is we open up four 125 year
olds females love Tom Brady the guy from
[ __ ] Lionsgate or whatever is like
I'm interested and um not Lions game but
you know what I mean
[ __ ] Searchlight or some [ __ ] not that
and um
and he said and so there it's Olivia
it's like [ __ ] some that older lady
named Olivia and then another one Sally
Field who's cool and then the other two
that you've seen in 900 things
and uh
uh my whole question is
who is this movie for
okay who's it for
usually you try to combine things that
are like-minded okay
so who's gonna go see this old ladies
maybe but also would they see this it's
about football
who's gonna go see this die hard
football fans maybe but it's about 4 165
year olds
ladies
so who's it for
if you're gonna make this [ __ ] movie
have it be with Michael Caine Michael
Douglas Michael Keaton and Michael
Chiklis okay that's the [ __ ] 80 for
Brady movie no guy who likes football is
gonna go see Sally Field
uh and [ __ ] you know what I mean
Olivia
and then the [ __ ] other one
they're not gonna go see it dude
also
for 180 year olds are not fans of Tom
Brady you might as well be making the
movie Transformers can't happen
so I'm just like it leads me to this
Zone I mean where I'm just all like
walking around saying Hollywood
80 for Brady you know
it rhymes
can't think of a worse title
80 for Brady
um
is what it is my baby
um
all right well I think that's a good
episode you know you guys I had a really
good time it's good to [ __ ] be back
in the 2023 era and uh you know we had a
good time and
um I appreciate you listening and uh
negotiating for Brady let me know how it
is
but yeah I'm gonna be in Seattle Sunday
the 29th tickets at chrisley.com and
then I have Lakeland
Florida I have uh Daytona and then I
have Jacksonville and then I have
Providence Rhode Island and then I have
New York oh I have San Antonio I have
New York
do I have Sugar Land right then anyway
crystalia.com Chicago it's just gonna be
Bonkers I just put Milwaukee on sale and
I just put uh Salt Lake City on sale
Salt Lake City selling my gangbusters
um so yeah go get your tickets
chrisley.com hey guys that's it for the
episode on YouTube if you want the uh
uncut version The Raw unedited uh with
commercial free then you just gotta go
to patreon.com christalia and let me
tell you something about that it's just
six bucks and let me tell you something
what else you get about that you get a
free episode a month which means you'll
get all the free episodes every month
that they come out but then also you'll
get all of the ones uncut and then also
you'll get about 20 backlog episodes
only
uh that patreon guys get so you can go
binge it now uh like it's the show 24 or
something so go to patreon.com
crystallia and uh peruse dude it's just
six bucks thanks guys
[Music]